he is known for his bold words but as he
addressed the nation for the first time
over the protests French president
Immanuel McComb tried to cut a humble
figure
repor Matt Bassett responsible
I accept my share of responsibility I
may have given you the feeling that I
wasn't concerned that I had other
priorities I also know that I've hurt
some of you with my statements we want a
France where one can live in dignity
through one's work and on this point we
have moved too slowly
I want to intervene quickly and
concretely on this issue
McCall said his government would raise
the minimum wage by some 100 euros a
month and exempt overtime from taxes
pensioners would also receive a tax cut
but many in the yellow vest movement
remains skeptical very nice speech but I
don't trust him at all and we need you
come on Sal ah I think he's getting
scared he's feeling the heat and that's
it he's lost all credibility and people
don't trust him he's got to go he took
one first big step he has many more to
take the increase of the minimum wage
that's a good thing hundred years is
very good but it wasn't all concessions
from Michel he refused protesters
demands to reinstate a wealth tax and
said he'll push ahead with plans to
overhaul the country's pension and
unemployment system as for the yellow
vests they've already announced new
protests for this weekend
no one knows whether the president's
actions will prevent scenes like these
from playing out across France again
between the studio I have Pascal tebow
he's a correspondent for Radio France
international here in Berlin welcome
Bhaskar now we saw president macro has
made some concessions he's announced
some measures but the question many are
asking how many financed them Macomb
will probably have to increase the
budget deficit of France
maybe these measures will cost a 10
billion euros we don't know exactly
maybe some euros more and maybe it will
maybe next year the French deficit will
will be three point five percent so
probably you will have to you will need
some talks we
Brussels because of course the limit the
official limit is by three percent and
France deficit should have been by 2.8
percent next year so of course an
increased budget deficit will create its
own problems but many of the protesters
are saying already that they are not
convinced by what macro has said they're
not satisfied with the measures he's
taken and they're going to continue with
their protests what more would they like
there are different reactions as we
heard and as also as I heard in in
French media's some are okay with some
of the concessions Mac homemade I've
probably the part of the protesters who
are more reasonable and that's probably
the hope of the president but of course
the movement will not stop today or
tomorrow and probably there will be more
protests on the next Saturday we will
see how many people will will take part
to that and he also Mac Hong condemned
quite strongly the violence's so maybe
his hope could be that some more
reasonable people accept these
concessions and and I took a larger
distance to the to the violent people
now these protesters calling for a
change of style from president macro or
a change of course I think both of
course Mike Hong is is is the president
it's small more or less a presidential
monarch in the French Constitution and
his is is he's hated from quite a lot of
people you you can say today and he's it
was quiet his arrogance or what people
thought it was quite arrogant from him
also explained that is imaged as his
popularity also is so low now so yes
yesterday evening he tried to change his
image and of course it could be also a
turned to a new politic with more social
with with more social topics more social
measures but without abandoning big
reforms that also what is said to there
big reforms are on the agenda for an
employment and for
pension system right Pascal tebow from
Radio France international thank you
very much for your thoughts
thank you